right now Stitch fix is offering our
listeners twenty dollars off their first
fix at stitchfix.com trash Tuesday
that's stitchfix.com trash Tuesday for
twenty dollars off today stitchfix.com
trash Tuesday you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show go
to neutrophone.com and enter code trash
to save ten dollars off your first
month's subscription that's ten dollars
off at neutrophool.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
free shipping on every order
offer only available to us customers for
a limited time order your THC products
for mood today for twenty percent off
your first order and free gummies go to
hellomood.com and use promo code trash
Tuesday that's
hellomood.com promo code trash Tuesday
for 20 off your order and free gummies
hi you guys I am so excited that I am
back doing stand up on the road I cannot
wait to see you guys on June 3rd I'll be
in Atlanta June 4th in Raleigh July 19th
through 22nd I will be in New York City
at Joe's Pub it's going to be iconic and
then I'll be in DC and Boston and you
can get tickets to all of these dates
and more at Esther onice.com hi sluggies
I miss you I am here at Annie wood
um I have my solo podcast it's so fun
it's every Thursday we've got a lot of
amazing guests and some really fun solos
with me and Todd so come join the party
every Thursday on YouTube at 9am
Pacific noon Eastern come hang also you
can see me on the road I am at
um
the Raleigh improv in Raleigh North
Carolina May 12th and 13th I'll be at
Baltimore at Magooby's June 2nd and 3rd
Salt Lake City Utah at Wise Guys uh June
9th and 10th San Antonio Texas I'll be
at the LOL Comedy Club June 23rd and
24th and I tickets just went on sale for
Austin in October so go to
annieleterman.com shows a lot more dates
are being added I'm going to be in
Philly San Francisco San Jose and I
cannot wait to see you please enjoy this
episode I miss these girls I'm so sad I
couldn't be there but I will be back
soon enough
[Music]
I think there's that angle and the fact
that like a lot of women enjoy watching
gay porn the fact that like male
sexuality becoming more publicly fluid
over the past couple years everyone has
some time to themselves during the
pandemic the video like boys just
kissing boys for fun now that's all like
in the Zeitgeist and like in the social
media landscape so I think we're headed
towards a more fun place for male
sexuality but it is it is still a hurdle
I have to say that I definitely have
some sort of internalized homophobia
where like still where even though the
culture is leading that way it is still
hard for me to be attracted to a man who
is also attracted to men and I don't
know I don't know if I can articulate it
Beyond just like an insecurity yeah
I mean what do you like how do you what
do you think when you hear me say that I
think that's not abnormal so many women
Express that with male Partners I think
part of it might also be the fear that
like if he's attracted to men he can get
a [__] anytime anywhere he just got
one he's getting one from me and he's
going to get another one right I can't
trust this man he has too many options
and what would you say to that I would
say it sucks that part of that is
correct
I think that like that that trepidation
that hesitation that fear concerning
like being with a guy who has had
same-sex attraction or with a guy who is
like actively bisexual or like just kind
of like no only one time I think I just
that's something that like
we as a culture have to discuss more and
that's also like part of whatever your
relationship rules are that gets into
also like what does monogamy mean for
people it also means like what would you
what would you want him to be able to do
because there's and this happens with a
lot of girls who say I'm bi but I'm in a
relationship with a guy and we're
exclusive some people invalidate their
bisexuality and they'll go well you're
not doing anything with girls so how do
you know I'm like well she has a
computer
I I believe in them right because I'm
sure people say that too because you're
by yeah and you're married to a man yes
so what where does that lead I tell them
I'm a [__] and then they go okay cool
cool we understand we got we got it no I
I'm buying a gay relationship the same
way you can be a dumb person in college
like you can do you can be in a place
where people like I'm surprised you're
here and they're like I'm surprised I'm
here too man that's what's up hell yeah
and you kalila are the exact opposite of
me where a man having had a gay
experience is drawn to me on because for
me it
it translates as someone who is just
maybe more sexually liberated more fun
um for me the bedroom is a place of like
playful spirit and the answer is always
yes for me
um and I equate that openness to having
more fun in the bedroom so it turns me
on my loins point in that direction of
someone being like I like it all I'm
like okay cool let's let's let's go but
will you ever feel like oh I'm missing a
penis and I can never offer that I you
know what I I so one of my
uh last relationships I was very
insecure about trans girls because he
was very attracted to trans girls and
it's what turned me on about him but I
do understand what you're saying where
it's like oh and now it's just extra
competition yes like I'm just looking
around being like oh [__] like he like I
know he likes that girl so I think
there's just more people to kind of be
insecure about me yeah
um but it was exactly what kind of
turned me on about him or I'm like oh
like I love that he's just you know like
for me I'll [__] ottoman you know
like bring me an inanimate object I
think I call like persons now
I don't think we use that terminology
anymore right we like right right
Iranian series
The Country we totally have been going I
haven't even introduced our guests okay
who is a very hilarious stand-up
comedian who I I feel like I discovered
all for myself I met you saw you perform
a hilarious set at the comedy seller I
was upstairs hearing I had to like go
down the stairs and watch you were so
funny you were the funniest person I've
seen there welcome to the show Jay
Jordan hey what's up and you've been on
The Tonight Show a bunch uh twice yeah
and you have hilarious sets on there and
like so thank you for being here thank
you for having me yes sir I remember uh
whenever you're in the the lounge at the
cellar there's upstairs and it's always
fun when sometimes you go up there you
plug up your phone you kind of get ready
for your set and you like just go wait a
second what's going on downstairs
something is shaking the room I don't
know this person so you have this fun
little like almost like uh Opera balcony
seat yeah at this point you kind of get
to become a good version of like uh
Statler and Waldorf and like the Muppets
where you're like who is this oh they're
funny so yeah that was really cool I
loved menu and I was aware of your stuff
but then when I came upstairs like holy
[__] yeah so so fun to meet you so I'm
very glad you're here I'm very glad we
can talk about this stuff with you
because
you're a bisexual man yeah which which
it's cool oh yeah who you guys everyone
who's scared to do it whether you're
famous or not you can be boring you can
be a flash driver and be bi did you know
that you don't have to just be a an
ex-member One Direction you can do all
things like
um well maybe this is something that we
should examine about myself so I'm very
attracted to women I love the company of
women I like making out with girls I
could you know I've had three sums all
of these things but I the one thing I
cannot do is like I'm just not a the
biggest fan of eating [__] and somehow
people have said well that makes you
absolutely not bi if you can go down on
a girl I'm like wait but I can do just
about I enjoy everything else it's just
not my favorite a lot of straight guys
say exactly
that's such a good that's so true a lot
of straight guys a lot of straight guys
say exactly what you say and I think
that I think going down on
people of varying genital representation
because that's like the way I like to
think about it like you you're basically
dealing with like either
um like a penis or you're dealing with
uh a [__] and a vaginal opening but
between that there's so much variance in
between like size shape everything there
so like the way I think about going down
on people I'm like oh this person
specifically
needs this in this way because like
going down on anyone is going to be a
surprise the first time you see anyone
naked you're always like okay there's no
no
do you uh do you ever think oh I just
want a girl to go down on me do you like
it when girls go down yeah okay yeah
yeah well I mean I think it's just maybe
like a mind shift for me like if I just
I think you're right a super top though
you might just love [__] I've never
related to that is that what I am I just
like be a super dumb top when it comes
to like you're you're like Sapphic
relationships you might just really love
strapping them up
as we look more excited than me
do you pack the dudes you're with I have
urges too okay that's what it is what
yeah like I do I I've never know you
know I've
I don't want to again out any of my
accents because there's only a handful
of them to choose from but um yeah I've
definitely you know
um soft dabbled okay soft launched
pegging okay yeah what is this
yeah you can't solve a lot of pegging
that
by the nature of the material it's
always hard
it's really not a tough launch
um but yeah like you're excited for me
well I just think that you
like your ability to diagnose her was
very beautiful well it's if you're like
oh I love [__] girls I'm not trying
to eat [__] I'm like oh you're like a
top you're just like I don't want to say
it but you like a dude who's like no I'm
trying to [__] I ain't trying to do all
that like you can go down on me and then
I'm gonna [__] you and then you know I'm
about to text you back or something but
that's like that was the energy I got
when you're like I don't have to eat
[__] oh my God thank you so much I
think you're absolutely right yeah it's
always like sex is like so many
different ingredients for so many
different people sometimes for multiple
people it's like yeah yeah and I think
um depending on what energy I receive
from someone that can vary as well
because I think that different people
bring out different parts of me yeah
um and if you
okay graphic I don't care if you're like
making out with a girl and like it's
mutual masturbation and you're both
using toys on each other they're like
good if you didn't go down but everyone
came like what is yeah what happened at
that point no one's gonna be like well
the sex was great but next time you have
to go down with me for like this amount
of time for this to actually count as a
lesbian experience right because we were
just talking about this yesterday on um
guys we thought and I I I love being a
cop or I'm a I think I'm a cop okay but
even the porn that I watch if it's like
a cuck situation I'm only looking at the
girl who's looking and assisting like so
um I really like sort of being like the
how do I say I guess kind of with big
like top energy like I like being the
orchestrator but more of like the voyeur
and the assistant like watching the
pleasure happen rather than
you know what I mean giving the pleasure
almost
like but that's also hot I feel like oh
yeah the the stuff you're describing is
just good I think no one I guarantee you
I am pretty sure it was like a room full
of people here and you're like sometimes
I just like to watch him get [__] and
like tell her what to do them no guy in
that car is gonna be like stop no no I
need you in there they're gonna be like
keep going please sweet your attitude
about all this is so refreshing because
I feel like kalila is sharing these like
things that are Kinks sort of and it I
feel like the nature here is to be like
well this means this about you and
you're weird and whatever but you're
just like oh that sounds like fun and
that why wouldn't you like that when
you're a bi guy a lot of your responses
to things is like that sounds pretty
cool let's uh let's try that out what
okay wow oh well that's new interesting
hmm what data did I collect from this
okay that's usually mine did you expect
or know that you would end up with like
marrying a man
um no I didn't know what my marriage
Journey was going to be because like I
was in a theater program I messed around
with girls up until like my junior year
of college and I messed around with guys
and girls and then I had like a secret
boyfriend and then I like hated that
because he was like Anna frat and not
out and like emotionally abusive I hate
to be redundant but I said he was in a
frat already it was just like a lot of
there's a lot of drama but I had like
all this extra drama with like a secret
gay relationship and I was like man no
that's not where I'm headed so I was
like oh I should probably date a girl
again but then I never like seriously
dated a girl I had like a girl who was
I'm very interested in us like trying to
make it work and then I met my now
husband and I was like holy [__] and so
I rebuffed his like relationship
advances for a little bit I was cool
like making out and like kind of kicking
it but I was always like I don't need a
relationship I'm like about to leave
like I don't need a relationship and
then like I was like holy [__] oh
relationships can be like wait a minute
good they can be mutually beneficial you
can care about these people who's been
hiding this secret from me probably they
relate to that so much right like all
the the like quote unquote relationships
in my early 20s compared to the one I'm
in now it's like a joke yeah it's
exactly that Discovery where you're like
oh someone can like me and want to talk
to me and so it's amazing so then
um we ended up kind of being long
distance and like but also being like
visiting each other a lot when I was in
grad school and he was finishing school
and then we moved to New York we moved
in together and then we kept getting
like
semi-engaged it was like oh this is like
a ring that means like we should keep
going this is like a ring that means
like you know one day maybe there'll be
another ring and if I think we're like
actually engaged and then we started
like setting the date and then we didn't
get married until last July but we
haven't been planning it for a little
bit but then we started to really plan
it the year before but I I didn't know I
was gonna end up married I see that come
from like I'm a child of divorce and
like my mom's a great woman but she
never remarried my dad never remarried
marriage I hadn't been to that many
weddings I think I'd only been to when I
moved New York I had never gone to a
wedding I went to one wedding for like
this Russian oligarch yeah I remember I
went with a friend from grad school and
it was a while I have like Rena tucks
and I was like this is like evil money
right
um and I definitely was like the only
black person there and so then in my
head I was like I don't know a lot about
weddings and marriages so I wasn't never
like seeking out a life partner I happen
to be lucky enough to find one to have
one find me a person who like I want to
make it work with well side note I feel
like that's always the secret to finding
one is not looking yeah but the culture
tells everyone yeah and like if you're
from like uh every from one of those
couples where the parents of childhood
sweethearts and they're telling you you
better be married by your 30 because
they want grandkids and like even if
they're not telling you they're like
winking about it all the time and like
constantly nudging you you have this
impetus to be like I guess I'll just let
this dude come at me so we can get
pregnant and get married and give these
[__] kids to my mom and dad so then I
can hate these kids and hate this man
and then cheat on him and people get mad
and it's like wow I've never met a man
who's from Venezuela of course I'm gonna
cheat like that
like that's what we do to so many of
these young girls in this country
so of course you know I did not receive
any pressure from my mom my dad died in
my teens but I didn't receive and even
to this day she still doesn't care about
every mom but I still let dudes come
inside me oh well that's because once
again we've established your first time
[Laughter]
biologically I feel like it's the
correct thing to do and then take care
of it later right get that Julie yeah
Julie's back pocket everyone
it's so weird that some people like oh
that's a breeding King because people be
like oh you have a breeding cake is that
what I have that no no I don't think you
do I just think you like sex
original recipe you do like that the way
that people have sex pulling out and
coming anywhere else is an extra step
that requires the timing of a gymnast I
want everyone to know there have been
times when someone's like I need you to
come in my face I was like you should
have said that minutes ago we are in the
uh we're in a space where you're gonna
that means you have to turn around I
have to also re-establish
you know what I mean
coming inside of people is the Christian
way that's what I should say yeah if you
if you're actually following the Bible
it is better that your seed fall in the
belly of a [__] than on the ground
thank you infidels you heathens it's
true I mean I always raise Catholic too
but it only makes sense that if he tries
to pull out that I just clamp them down
yeah you should say what do you think
the pope will have to say about this
exactly yeah
Eli spring is here and I'm pretty sure I
mean look at me I need a branch for
whammy I I need you to have one yeah I
don't know who is wardrobe you robbed
but it was a man you're dressing up as a
swamp
listen I'm glad Stitch fix is our
sponsor because I'm going to be needing
them so much these next couple yes I had
a I had an experience where I had to
take all these mushrooms for my cluster
headaches and I was like looking at all
of the boxes of things that I buy and
all these clothes that I have and I was
like this is It's too many clothes I
need a situation where I can just get
clothes see if I like them and turn them
back I have so many things that are not
too hard to retire yeah you need it to
be more curated like Stitch fix actually
makes you feel like you have a partner
that's helping you curate clothes and
especially for like spring and summer
like we need we need to freshen up and
what I love about Stitch fix is you take
this simple questionnaire and then your
match of the stylists and clothes get
sent to your door you keep the ones you
like and you return the ones you don't
send it with that they bring they give
you all the stuff to return it it's so
easy they also like want to know what
your price range what's your style like
they ask you the right questions to kind
of get to know you and they have over a
thousand Brands and styles which is very
good there's variety good good selection
and you get to try your pieces at home
before you buy them so you just keep
what you love you send back the rest
plus it's the shipping returns and
exchanges are all free and they have a
wide range of uh you know sizes they
have extra small for extra 3XL for me
and Kyla and and there's no subscription
required simply order a refresh as
needed or set it and forget it with
regular seasonal fixes you're in
complete control and right now Stitch
fix is offering our listeners 20 off
their first fix at stitchfix.com trash
Tuesday that's stitchfix.com trash
Tuesday for twenty dollars off today
stitchfix.com trash Tuesday you guys 30
million women are impacted by weekend or
thinning hair we're not alone well
that's what happens weekend oh crazy
weekend that's what happened to me when
I turn 30 when I got off my birth
control I could not stop the shedding I
was just losing hair losing hair and I
would you know you you stick your hair
in the shower
my whole wall was just hair loss but
there is a solution and you can trust it
to deliver actual results okay
neutrophil is a simple addition to your
daily routine and what I love about it
is it's actually all stuff that's good
for you it's not a gimmick and you use
it and you actually get results if you
stay consistent but that's exactly what
makes me believe in the product it's not
an overnight fix I've used it for years
um it wasn't until maybe my third or
fourth month that I started to release
see results and that's how I like
um that's how I like it I don't want
something that promises an overnight fix
because then you're like oh is this
gonna fall out of my head very soon
it's so good it's the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
your hair growth thickness and visible
scalp coverage and neutral supports
healthy hair growth from within by
targeting the five root causes of
thinning which are stress hormones
environment nutrition and metabolism
through whole body Health neutrophil has
three unique formulas to support women
throughout all stages of life including
postpartum and menopause each for each
formula is physician formulated using
natural drug free medical grade
ingredients in consistently effective
dosages so you get the most reliable
results
three thousand plus Top Doctors and
stylists recommend neutrophil as an
effective and high quality solution for
healthier hair and I also recommend it
and in a clinical study 86 percent of
women reported improved hair growth
after six months yeah I use neutrophil
every day I love it it's okay I'm
excited I'll take it it's like my nice
little like thing it's a nice thing I do
for myself I love that we're sponsored
by them I'm like honored I love it I
give it to my sister-in-law I give it to
everyone so good you can grow thicker
healthier here and support our show by
going to neutrophil.com and entering
promo code trash to save ten dollars off
your first month subscription this offer
is only available to you as customers
for a limited time plus free shipping on
every order get 10 off at nutriful.com
spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
now I was my dad's side of the family
was Catholic that's one of my favorite I
told uh it's the silliest and stupidest
joke but it's one of my favorite jokes
as I did it on my first time on The
Tonight Show I was like my dad saw the
family as Catholic that's right black
Catholics do exist we say hail Mary J
Blige
it's such a funny silly joke The Roots
loved that joke
good with you being raised Catholic but
you also being like a sexually liberated
person do what remnants of Catholic
guilt do you have any oh all of it and
especially because I didn't grow up in
America so I grew up in the Philippines
okay yes like very deep deeply also
um they you know growing up now they
have certain you know things in place
that actually help women and Family
Planning and but growing up
um
um birth control pills were illegal yeah
abortion illegal everything illegal
illegal illegal colonialism does
colonialism literally Spaniards go to
the Philippines and go first of all put
some clothes on secondly you worship
this God now and if you don't you're
going to hell what's hell I'm glad you
asked this is like right no exactly that
so
um I
it it's I think the the guilt that I
carry is on a different level than I
imagined like growing up in America and
being like Catholic here or maybe not or
you're in the Northeast like Catholic
Catholic schools basically like I know
people who are still kind of like
allowing themselves to enjoy things
because of their upbringing in the
Catholic church because it kind of
consumes a lot of people's existence
it's not just Mass on Sunday it's school
Monday through Friday it's a religion
class and or like a chapel section of
your curriculum every day those five
days you get a Saturday off if you play
church league basketball you're going
back to do more churchy [__] then you go
to mass on Sunday and the whole time
you're told listen not only is this the
right way this is the right and only
Christian way like this is the one true
faith if you don't do these things you
will go to hell hell is not metaphorical
it is real you will go there and so
there's this like that is that is like a
holy [__] I can't believe it but I hear
it and Esther guess what like you're not
telling teenagers this you're telling
eight-year-olds this you know eight year
olds that and of course an eight year
old's gonna be like oh my God what and
I'm going to hell yes you're going to
hell how could I stop this from
happening and then imagine and then
imagine me being an eight-year-old
having been molested by a family member
as being my first like sexual experience
and then having the guilt of looking at
that family member and feeling like I
had a crush on this adult yeah because
it warped my brain but then you have the
Catholic shame and then there I was in
my teens just trying to suck every dick
I could find feeling terrible about
myself and then not being able to
masturbate because I felt shame and to
this day still cry crying after sex like
I burst into tears when I come that's
Catholic guilt I think all of those
things like you don't you can you know
release and you can intellectualize your
upbringing and say okay this happened
because of this and I'm no longer a part
of this institution than you in ways
that maybe sometimes you can't even make
sense of because it just seems so absurd
to be like why do I have a crush on the
person who assaulted me or why am I
bursting into tears after you know
having this glorious threesome like it's
so [__] weird how it just stays in
you it stays in the body 100 wait so
what is your then remnants of do you
have Catholic guilt that stays so I was
raised uh like Southern Baptist so the
thing that still kind of happens to me
is that I didn't get a bunch of like
Hellfire and brimstone preached at me a
lot but there is this tendency to still
try to be like oh I am a good Southern
Christian boy even though I'm doing like
all this stupid gay stuff I'm a comedian
I live in like New York City but like
part of my identity is still being like
a good mama's boy I was able to like
have a fairly positive relationship with
my I bring in the church because for me
it was a little bit less about like
punishment and way more about community
so like my grandmother was a big part of
our church like the church Rec Center is
like where I like play basketball I made
some of my first friends like church was
always like seen as like the place where
you could like go get something to eat
there was never like a big fear of like
punishment for me from church so the way
that I kind of like deal with any of my
[__] it's like all like internalized
homophobia that I still like kind of
work around and not internalize
homophobia and since I'm going to hell
just like oh people won't like you if
you're like your authentic sub oh look
make sure you're like not too gay like
don't be too gay your homeboys will know
like it's the it's the feeling of when
you're in elementary school when you're
in middle school and you meet a new boy
and instead of being able to ever say
that boy's cute what you say as a little
bible is that guy's so cool you guys
know how cool that guy is he's new he's
got interesting stories oh my God look
at his shoes he's so cool we should hang
out with the new guy and everyone's like
why don't you care about this news so
much Jay we're your friends who's this
piece of [__] I'm like we should be nice
to him though
um
you just find ways around it I remember
like looking at my two best friends in
high school there were these they were
like they were they were Twins and both
of them were cute and what's so funny is
that like I never had like a crush on
them but they definitely informed the
way that I flirted with boys eventually
when I would so I'd be too broey
sometimes I had to like re-learn that I
was like oh I can actually like approach
this in a way that is intentionally
romantic I don't always have to be like
yeah dude because that's like fake
that's fake it's me me going yeah dude
is being like Oh don't make this gay
don't make this gay sex we're about to
have two gay dogs
you're holding back yeah something yeah
so I had to learn I had to like escape
from that it's also I was fortunate
enough that I was always able to be out
on stage so I moved New York in 2015 so
when you look at like 2015
comedy scene in New York is a bunch of
open mics and so like I was never not
gonna be out on stage only because
sometimes when you see a comic and
there's one thing that they're like
dancing around are there a bunch of
neutral pronouns used when talking about
dating stories you're like
um what about
um Comics who just straight up like hate
women
on stage oh well here's the sad part
about that I think that misogyny is such
an easy
hack I say this not hacking the way the
comics use it as a kind of like insult
I'm saying it's a hack to get into like
a lot of the American psyche because
culturally so many people hate women if
you go oh man she's being a [__] a
crowd of men and women will be like he's
right she is being fit I like
low-hanging fruit she's low hanging
fruit lowest common denominator it's the
easy way to kind of have like a
plurality of laughs where I would argue
that like hating men is also fun on
stage but so many people go oh she's
just hating man she's just hating man
and then a comic on stage I took much of
her credit will be like yeah cause y'all
be raping people and people in the
audience will be like
she got a point yeah I forgot about the
rapes you should have led with the rapes
it's like a very it's also like
I think that the reason people still use
misogyny if we look at comedy in like a
big picture is that like if we look at
domestic comedy like back way back like
ancient Greek domestic comedy and it all
it trickles down all the way to like The
Honeymooners and The Flintstones what
people thought was funny was this man
this large man this brunette man this
overweight man this hairy man this ugly
man has a tiny wife and she is mean to
him but because they're married it's
funny because the power Dynamic has been
shifted physically and visually we have
contrasting figures we also have
different voices he's low she's High
he's normal she's annoying we have all
of these things that are baked into
Western theater and baked into like the
Western idea of Comedy so we're playing
on very old tropes and the people who
are able to like up in those tropes are
seen as like groundbreaking but also the
people who like continue those tropes
they may not be able to articulate what
they're doing but they know what they're
doing right whenever someone is like oh
my wife is like getting on to me about
this thing The Crowd Goes oh I know
where I've seen this before I'm allowed
to laugh at this and and the people who
can like flip it on his head a person
who flipped on their head and it sucks
like now they're all so very crazy but
Roseanne was able to go no I'm being
annoying on purpose and I'm gonna be me
and you're like holy [__] okay you're
flipping on his head a little bit it's
um it's cool to look at it from a
theatrical standpoint because then you
can be like oh that's where this is
coming from a little bit Yeah I it's
interesting like because when we see the
man complain about his wife it is
familiar we're allowed to laugh but then
you don't you could also argue that now
we've seen it so much it is
it is boring yeah hacky it is stupid
it's like offensive yeah and you want to
see what the next step is you want this
man to be aware that he's becoming the
man that people are making fun of and
him to reflect and go oh what does it
say about me that I've become this
version of this guy now because you know
what the groundbreaking thing was like
two years ago for a guy to be like hey I
kind of I think my wife's awesome people
like
yeah I kind of like this lady lady oh my
God you know her name I do know her name
whoa this is what what wait a minute
next thing you're gonna tell me you're
taking care of the kids sometimes I do
give this man a medal he deserves an
award you know their names I know all
their names
who's at the door donut
we don't bark in public it's
embarrassing don't let people know
you're a dog
um one of my favorite uh
uh bits of yours is when you talk about
um women just dating
ugly humans because I I feel like you
were speaking directly to me I I also
want to add a caveat the reason I make
that joke is because women and a lot of
people are so
willing to look past conventional
attractiveness to find like what they
find is actually sexy about a guy so
they're able to say oh this is sexy
about him it's not hot but this is sexy
about him oh I don't no no I don't want
to post this man but he is he's
definitely like [__] my brain loose
like I need you to know you know what I
mean there's also this idea
that it never in my wildest dreams would
I ever come up with the idea that a
woman is even capable of being ugly on
stage in front of cameras so of course
if you want to take anyone down a peg
you shoot for a man because if you call
a man ugly his response can be like a
stupid [__] though and you're like
great that's if you call a girl ugly
people gonna be like what do you mean by
that what's ugly about this girl so I
think that like I wanted to really
figure out the the ins and outs of that
Joe there's also like that joke that's
what came from first of all
there's this picture I want to say of
Jennifer Connelly with the puppet from
Labyrinth like the really of the troll
one and I tweeted like years ago I was
like straight couples in there
and found the Tweet if you can and uh I
was like oh okay let me see if I can
build this I was like working on it and
then there was this idea that like all
these articles came out over the past
two years are like the bng's magazines
or Beyond these online like Publications
that will be like ladies you know what's
in huge eyebrows and ugly men and I'd be
like don't tell these girls they have to
date ugly man just tell them they can
date who they want that's different and
so I was like oh okay let me come up
with something and I wrote the bib and
then the funniest part of that is I did
it at the seller and a comic was like
you know why you know why these girls
date these ugly men because they want
that money and so and so listen to me as
when I tell you then then I took that
part and added it to the end of my joke
and so I have another section where I go
uh my friend's an old school comedian
what's the word for that he's massaging
this and he said that these women date
these ugly men just so they can get
their money I'm like yeah I know ugly
men have money I've been on a boat
before and so
I like wanted to take what he said and
like call him a misogynist but also like
add to my joke and I I told him that I
was gonna put him in there and he's like
hell yeah and I was like I was like
you're so funny that me calling you a
massage and she's like I'm in the joke
yeah yeah dog we ain't here my favorite
part of that joke is actually when you
call out which I've never heard anyone
point this out and it's so well observed
is that women are willing to look past
looks and see other things that are
attractive in a man but men will never
do that for women no no no no no no no
no no no no no men and Society in
general but men will be like well first
of all she's very hot so that's why
she's allowed to be such a terrible
person that's why she was allowed to
poison me you understand she tried to
poison you yeah she put antifreeze in my
drink but C cups come on man what I'm
supposed to do not
I guess that is a benefit well I think
that I just have a completely different
um like I I don't know where my taste in
men comes from
or maybe that I grew up in Asia and
watched a lot of like sumo wrestling and
like salivated over these men but that's
that but that's like not
I'm gonna tell you something that you're
gonna be like what so many gay guys love
an actual big man we've kind of
conflated big with musculars sometimes
in America but like an actual big man
like a large man is so hot their entire
game magazines like there's a gay I want
to say publication called beef that's
just like huge dudes like bellies pecks
arms huge dunes and like that to me
whenever people talk about like we're
for someone to be like I don't
understand my attraction that person
would have to be like part lizard for me
to be like that
can usually be like oh yeah I see it
yeah but I I you know my ex is five foot
four and and portly is that pleasantly
plump just like a thick dude yeah he's
just got like I like his thick Korean
thighs but I remember just hearing his
voice for the first time and just being
like Oh like he's extremely attractive
to me like and everyone telling me like
kalila like you know what I mean like
because there was in their eyes like uh
disparity yeah but in my eyes I just
always thought he was hot but I think
that that is so cool because you just
said his voice was so [__] hot like
that's a thing that we allow and I wish
we were allowed more people to do but
like before you'd be like that's the
thing that was hot because sometimes
when hotness is only visual you'd be
like well let's like keep looking
nothing turns my [__] into dust more
than like a hot dude with the wrong
voice
like I'm such a voice person like I
don't care if you're Chris Hemsworth if
you're not coming correct with your
vocal cords I am out okay I am out voice
is important I think like hands are very
hands are so important see this is this
is but this is like fun do you guys
understand like this is why I like
talking about sexuality and Kinks and
attractions with different people
because this conversation for other
groups of people is so superficial and
so predictable they're like oh I like
boobs butts lips
and money and where it's like you were
just like I need a voice and you're like
I need like hands hands are like super
important to me I have people in my life
they're like a wrist like a thick wrist
like a good forearm like they just love
and this isn't and these are people who
aren't in the fisting I do know people
who are
come on
oh that's so interesting yeah I I think
that I look at different things for sure
I look like it things maybe as like I
guess a whole package and I I was I was
just talking to Esther about this
um like I always thought that oh maybe I
don't have any preferences you know I
don't have a type maybe I just like
whatever you know seems attractive is
attractive to me I don't know what that
criteria is but then I was like
I don't find white guys like attractive
which I think is such a superpower in
our life
and I'm trying to figure out it's just
good formative years in the Philippines
you were inoculated against it you got
the vaccine
I do have the keloid yeah prove it here
in America you you fed a diet of white
guys like from jump
what's crazy though is your fed fake
white guys y'all wanted something crazy
you know okay so like sometimes you
you'll be like oh these are like the
white poster children of like America
Americana and one person that people
would put up there is Zach Morris Zach
Morris Indonesia have Indonesia yeah
correct that's a wild yeah he's half
asian and in a minute he dyes his hair
dark you see it you're gonna absolutely
see it
but because he was fed to us as a white
guy right like oh it's just a white boy
no yeah because he was blonde on the
show but Darkness
he's talking about trash Zach Morris at
the Trashy his die job and he's not like
you know Eastern Asian he's like one of
us he's jungle Asian he is Indonesian he
is my neighbor yeah he's Southeast Asian
yeah that is crazy that's hot right but
that's hot but like if you give Zach
Morris that arc on Saved by the Bell
earlier maybe it does help people go oh
I do like non-white guys or I like white
guys but I also like Indonesian guys I
think that so many
it sucks when you're like representation
matters in Hollywood but that probably
would have helped a lot of little
non-white boys be like oh I'm pretty
cool I can be like a class favorite but
it's I mean but we also have like AC
Slater being like a really really hot
Chicano like it's like
I think that
white guys just get like put to the
front more because from a marketing
standpoint you want other white guys to
be like okay I'll buy that but like more
power to you if you can be like white
guys I ain't down for it well it sort of
speaks to what you you're saying before
he started rolling which is like that I
said a bunch of crazy [__] I outed a
bunch of people in Hollywood can't get
the tapes back you'll never know but
like you you know if an actor comes out
and he's gay and then
he can't maybe he his career suffers
from it and it's not just because women
want to you know be think and fantasize
about being with that guy but it's also
because men want to be able to look up
to superheroes and they're probably have
internalized homophobia and they don't
want to if it's a gay person yeah is the
reason people don't talk about Richard
Pryor being queer is the reason people
don't talk about Marlon Brando being
queers we don't talk about James Dean
being queer it's the reason people don't
want to talk about it is that's those
are facts yeah
the Marlon Brando thing makes sense for
me somehow and it just makes him a lot
better young Marlon Brando I look buy
[__] James Dean buy [__] Richard Pryor
ah
yep
whoa I honestly old Marlon Brando I
would go for oh Marlon Brando and The
Godfather yeah no like dementia
is there any
chance that misogyny is rooted from men
being jealous of women that other men
want to [__] us oh well them is that
possible it's all connected because like
fear of homophobia is fear of misogyny
because fear of homophobia is rude and
like Oh I'm a man I can never be treated
like a woman if I treat like a woman I
don't mean taking on dates I mean
penetrated so people are scared that men
won't be doing the thing they think men
are supposed to do which is being the
penetrative partner instead of being the
person being penetrated in sex it just
come in so much of misogyny boils down
like well women are less than me because
I get to [__] women and it's like no
that's why people get so mad about
lesbians that's why people get so mad
about
anyone who doesn't follow whatever the
kind of
codified sexual hierarchy is and it's
like you [__] you can't do that you're
up ending the rules we establish that's
why so many CIS men get mad about trans
women because this is what they say they
go you're a man why would you ever want
to go down a peg you want to move up the
ranks and it's like no they want to live
authentically they want to be themselves
and they're like but why you already
have everything you're a man and you go
but that's not what they want and they
go who could not want this and you go
she doesn't it's her she doesn't want it
it blows people's minds when you
do something that they don't want to do
and they go well why would you do that
because I'm my own person I have
autonomy I act I have that too and
someone's like I want white pizza I'm
like it needs sauce
I like white pizza not white boys white
pizza you're okay it's a piece of pizza
Blanca so you red sauce red sauce is
what makes a pizza pizza for you thank
you what makes a pizza pizza for you pie
anything okay all the toppings whatever
variation or whatever weird creative
whims speak to you is what pizza is I
don't have rules about food if it looks
good I I hate when people are like this
is how you eat this the authentic way
shut the [__] up she got opinion on
everything she is every [__] oh it
makes pizza pizza what makes pizza pizza
dough
um I can I like a red sauce but for some
pizzas you don't need it and because the
chef will be like no no if you do that
you'll ruin this pizza so I usually try
to respect the chef
whatever it is I don't care eight inches
12 inches put it in there we're talking
about pizza you guys oh my God I am so
not a size queen that is the one thing
that I will I one time I oh this we'll
talk about it so high he was a
decathlete and such a great guy I could
have ended up dating him if his dick
wasn't I didn't even care so much about
how big it was it's just that it hooked
downwards oh but I did not know what I I
was I told him like before I left I was
like respectfully I don't know what to
do with that yeah I am just fully
intimidated like congratulations like
goodbye yeah that is uh that's
definitely like
a learning curve
whether you're new to cannabis or an Old
Pro there's no denying that many of the
products on the market seem iffy at best
and when you want to relax if he is the
last way that you want to feel mood puts
an end to guessing games it's 100
federally legal Delta 8 and Delta 9 THC
that you can have shipped straight to
you no doctors no waiting just
Affordable Legal THC for a limited time
mood is giving our listeners free Delta
9 gummies and 20 off your first order
visit hellomood.com and use our code
trash Tuesday now what we love about
mood here is that it's very curated in
their selection so you can get an option
for when you want to feel energized okay
creative if you're wanting to be
inspired like you pick the creative
blend focused there's euphoric erotic
sleepy chill social body Soother
um for me I definitely like the chill
one at night like especially after set
and I'm like all amped up and I need to
calm down I need like I take a chill
gummy
um I'll do creative if I'm just feeling
like oh I want I want to see where my
mind can really go
um it's definitely helped me a lot in
like those areas of my life and however
you like to take THC mood has you
covered great for both beginner and
Veteran users great tasting gummies
classic flower convenient pre-rolls and
so much more ready for a good time
without the guesswork order your THC
products from mood today and for 20 off
your first order and free gummies go to
hellomood.com and use the promo code
trash Tuesday that's hello
m-o-o-d.com promo code trash Tuesday for
20 off your order and free gummies
as a person with a penis
and I'll say this like also as a black
guy with a penis like whenever like
post Middle School into High School you
start learning about other people's
dicks whether it be like porn that you
watch or like your friends dicks so like
the size the kind of size demon is
always in your ear the size shame demon
it's like you're not big enough there
are bigger dicks there are bigger dicks
there are bigger decks your dad's not
big enough especially because keep in
mind you're 13. of course they're bigger
dicks so then you really have to have
like enough Faith patience and like
self-awareness to be like okay but my
dick is my dick and I'm happy about it
and I'm saying this as a person with a
dick that like I love and lots of other
people love and I get compliments on all
type but like it's like not all the time
I get I get very aware of like
girls saying they're not size queens and
then every guy's response is like yeah
we should just saying that and it's like
what like you just invalidated the
person that you do you want to have a
big dig for your boys or do you want to
have a big dick for the dirty [__]
guys really do invalidate that you're so
right we were like recently on a like a
male a big male comedians podcast I
think we talked about this yeah and they
totally rolled their eyes at us and like
didn't want to have any any of it and
but they just men don't want to believe
that I I felt like maybe I was being
like a pygmy girl or being like too
polite I'm like no it's this is the fact
like my Canal does not enjoy a certain
new level we aren't announced it
um I'll even say this like uh if you
have a penis
I was just that well I don't care this
is this is the podcast we'll do it
um you can like
when you're bumping someone's cervix or
you like feel their the value oh okay
two like you like
it's just like one of those things where
like sexually what's pleasurable for
some people
isn't pleasurable for other people and
like I'm saying this also as a guy who
like hooks up with guys and who's
married to like an amazing guy like
people truly don't understand that there
can be like a full-on like okay I need a
break from this dick and people won't
you you know you're like you're saying
your Canal like your vaginal Canal
doesn't enjoy like crazy crazy crazy
[__] and that's true for people's butts
too like you know so many people if
everyone's dick is destroying everyone
then everyone will be like I can have
sex for two days all right right and
that's so true and which is why on that
same podcast we talked about husband
dick where this is a dick I can enjoy
regularly
Bailey and with no damage to the Rouge
in my you know what I mean in my vagina
guys get so guys get so scared because
penis size is like the one thing that
like they think is like the big biggest
gotcha like it's always like an insult
that you can use to like cut down
another man it's always like an insult
that like you hear growing up it's like
one of those things that we're fully
indoctrinated in yeah but then like
whenever we start talking about penis
size and we also have to realize that
like oh well we really really can't
start to like until we see everyone's
dick we can't always be like oh that
person has a little dick that means you
have to see so many dicks as a straight
man to even know I if I'm attracted to a
person it doesn't really matter like
nothing else really matters it's like if
I like you
I like everything do you know what I'm
saying yeah even feet well
you know whatever like I was jokingly
doesn't have like Talons yeah I've uh
I've also like and this happens whenever
you like expand these conversations you
have people who have different life
experiences than you like there's also
the idea kind of of like if penis size
is the only gauge of masculinity then
there are a lot of trans men who end up
getting insulted by everyone being like
well if you're a man your dick has to be
this big cause like they're they're
experience in their bodies is completely
different than cisman so there's also I
think we're learning how to talk about
these things and yes for comedic
purposes we have a bunch of jokes about
a bunch of stupid [__] that are just
short-handed versions of like things
that we all have like been told but I
think that
I think that more people are learning
how to articulate what y'all are saying
it's like well I like this guy and this
dick is part of this guy so I like this
guy because I think it's a good way to
put it it would be worse to say oh I
like this dick
and it happens to be with this dude who
I don't like at all because that to me
is like
that's like a that's an objectification
that if you did if you did that to women
people be like you're kind of a monster
right right it's interesting how
horrible that sounds if it's a guy
saying it yeah and from a girl it's like
well it's like I like these two holes
and those boobs and the rest of
hurricane I think for me the way I look
at it is just like I'm de-centering
genitalia oh yes like I'm not genitalia
forward I'm like I'm around like I like
I have to like whatever is around the
genitalia and whatever exists in between
those legs good if I like you I think I
think we're good that sounds
exceptionally sane to me yeah like
that's great but also I will say there's
always going to be a part of
and you have to fight it and you have to
like push against it there's always a
part of guys
brains in America I can't speak to
experiences other places but in Western
culture that's like oh she's lying yeah
lying my whole life It's gotta be that
I'm lying like God forbid that I have my
own preferences and that I've sort of
just like stuck by it I it always
appears oh that is like the label that
you've had for so long because of your
past relationship it's like because she
was dating a man who's a small Asian guy
and she's beautiful everyone's like
she's a gold digger yeah just because
you're beautiful and they think that the
guy you're with is ugly but I think it
speaks more to how what they think of
him than what they think of me which is
really insulting for him especially if
they're fans of his right it's like all
of his fans are always like you know
just oh okay okay put everything I put
everything together her ex's box yeah
yeah and so like our entire relationship
we were together for 10 years has been
like Bobby you know she's this and she's
that and she's only got to be with you
for this and it's like you guys you're
calling him
ugly you're calling you're also taking
away his agency you're taking away the
fact that he might be able to make his
own decisions at 51 years old
we're raised with him on Mad TV and he's
very funny and Charming enough that he
definitely could like land some days
there's a wild part whenever someone's
surprised that a male comic has a hot
girlfriend like didn't he just charm all
of y'all strangers do you think he can't
do it for one person it's always so
weird that's the one thing because
sometimes if it's just like this super
boring quiet
non-interesting person you'll be like
what is the appeal but with a male comic
a dating a hot person I'm always like
welcome
yeah easy to see yeah it's and
especially it's funny that you're like
and because there are fans of his
they're like I like him but why does she
yes exactly you just said you like him
yeah but he's mine you don't need to
like him where do you like him why do
you like them I mean you pay to see him
yeah I didn't have to pay I had heart
eyes and I said okay and I open my legs
it was a simple thought jealous yeah
they just want to [__] him
I did it
um your other bit that I love so much is
you talk about your wedding oh yeah and
you say that like you you're was just
introducing gay people to other gay
people but they've already had sex with
each other yeah so you can bear in New
York City you spend most of your wedding
day introducing gay men who live in New
York City to other gay men they have
already slept with which was partially
my experience at my wedding because uh I
went to two weddings kind of like before
my wedding in both weddings particularly
one wedding had so many people that had
like some sort of History myself uh my
husband
included in like that whole thing where
I was like this is silly this is so
silly that so many of these people at
this reception I've either seen naked in
person or on my phone this is hilarious
oh my God
and you I just kind of want to also talk
about like the the silliness of that but
also the fun part of that there's also
an element to that story where
because gay Social Circles a lot of
people [__] first then become friends
later you have that aspect of it too
where it's like oh we hooked up but he's
like a really cool dude we're probably
not gonna hook up again but we we should
definitely watch drag race together I
like the pragmatism of that there's just
like there's something just really nice
like even I think like when I see my
married gay friends like how they handle
their relationships with their views on
monogamy they're kind of like
flexibility on certain ideas that other
people are very rigid about like I kind
of like there's like a relief I almost
wish that like I do have like gay man
Envy in that way there's some there's
some part of gay culture around 2015
that was like we have to get married and
then a lot of people got married and
they're like
I still want to party though they're
like
I didn't want to get married like that I
want to get married the way I wanted to
get married and then still be able to
can we and so you saw a lot of people
kind of have a conversation Dan Savage
talk a lot about like his view on
monogamoush people like what monogamy
means for different people and the
easiest part of gay relationships having
much more flexibility with that is the
fact there's never the fear and this is
an old old
fear there's never the fear that a child
isn't yours so like a lot of straight
guys their biggest fear their biggest
fears that child isn't mine that child
isn't mine so when I die someone who
isn't of my bloodline is going to get my
stuff it becomes very
um Game of Thrones it actually becomes
like very old kind of like it's it's
like early modern period it's it's close
to like Shakespearean times but it's
ruined this idea of like the great chain
of being so if you have God angel you're
a guy like Jesus angels and then like
closer to the top you have like royalty
so if you're Royal your blood is
different your entire existence is
different and if you're not Royal then
you can't get up there so there should
never be interaction with the between
these two so we need like an actual
clear line of succession and we need to
make sure that only people with good
royal blood or [__] other people like
that that's why they have to [__] their
first cousins and second cousins and
[__] so then here's what happens if
infidelity occurs then that means a
stable boy [__] a princess that means
that princess is gonna give birth to a a
hybrid a [__] bastard that's what
bastard was such an insult because you
were bastardizing the line you were
basically ruining the the great chain of
being because you're dirty poor person
blood was mixing with royal blood and
now we don't know who to give this stuff
to this is true yeah and so it works its
way all the way down to now in American
society if a guy works 30 years for a
company he has two kids he has his
firstborn son and he's blonde and his
wife is blonde but oh his [__]
brunette when he dies the milkman's son
is gonna get his [__] and it just ruins
people that's why there's there's so
scared of being coupled in they're so
scared of basically being tricked by
this evil woman who couldn't control her
urges and she let this other man come
inside of her and now he is gonna get
your stuff it's all stuff based and with
you're gonna get your Happy Meal too yes
but with gay man you're like
you those kids are going in the toilet
you know what I mean it's like it's
different
oh that's such a good way to put it I
know I always sort of thought that it
had it in which it might but like that
gay men had to fight for just the right
to like have their love and like exist
that it's like well they fought this
hard for it they want to you know that's
such a beautiful way to think about it I
think that's definitely part of it but
whenever you don't have to deal with
like inheritance and like full you don't
have to deal with like infidelity
leading to like kids that aren't yours
you are so calm about it you like don't
stress at all because the thing that
happened is sex not a child right people
get people get super worked up about it
vice versa right for women
um thinking that another woman will be
impregnated yeah right so yeah so it's
like because it's resource Garden
because of that other woman it is
resourcing if the other woman gets
impregnated then that means oh [__] he's
gonna have to devote time money
resources and focus on her because he's
going to have to take care of that kid
I'm going to have less stuff because she
is going to require more stuff right now
there was a it's so sad but you can see
people's wheels turning it's like no no
if you get her pregnant oh my [__]
God you have taken everything from me
you were supposed to give me that baby
vis-a-vis you were supposed to give me
that stuff you're taking stuff away from
me it is stuff it's ownership of things
it's cars it's houses it's money it's
time it's heirloom yeah it's your come
is mine yeah yeah
which is also hot if you ever said to
someone
yeah
I'm sorry yeah and I was like well I
need to go you guys I gotta get out of
here real quick it's that kind of day in
New York it's hot enough if someone was
like you come as mine I'm like you're
right
it's only yours yours for now how much
you need
[Music]
didn't know I'd be getting such a like
full-on education today I feel so
enlightened this is great I I love being
able to tie this stuff back to sex
because we think oh this doesn't relate
to sex it doesn't relate to sex at all
it's totally relates to sex it's so
interconnected because sex is at the
core of so many of the fights that
people have sex is at the core of like
weird racism that people have sex is at
the core is like the fear is like the
feminization of Asian man and like the
hyper masculization of black men that's
sexual at its core a lot of people are
like my daughter's Never Gonna date a
black guy not because they don't want to
create a beautiful Drake but because
they don't want that mythological huge
black dick ruining and or raping their
white daughter
what is okay what is your opinion on I
posted this and I said this on this
podcast a few weeks ago and people were
upset with me oh I love it but I have
like a a I guess you could call it a
kink or a fetish or look I saw
Schindler's listed a pivotal oh this is
the Nazi thing yeah the the guard thing
I'm would that is a fantasy for me of
Like A Nazi to save me
I think uh what would like a therapist
say Kinks and thoughts aren't reality
it'll you aren't seeking that out it is
the king that you express and people are
allowed to have opinions on it but it's
just because of the taboo nature of
sexuality plus the taboo nature of this
subject it's a power Dynamic I mean if
we look okay we if we take away like the
ethnic cleansing element of it we let
that [__] happen I'll let it happen as
like a major subplot point and plot line
on Orange Is the New Black because if
you're a CEO no [__] inmates you
raped someone because they don't have
power in jail
is true yeah that's a great Point yeah
now also before we finish up I want to
ask you what is your sort of do you have
any like advice or thoughts on me or
anyone else who does deal with this
internalized homophobia of like not
wanting to be attracted to a bisexual
man
um I think articulating it and saying oh
I'm having this feeling about this what
about this makes me less attractive to
him is like the first step and then the
second step is kind of like and this is
gonna sound silly watch more gay porn
watch more gay porn and be like oh okay
I kind of like this oh this is watch
more MMF porn so like there's a girl
there maybe the fun part for you is like
fighting over the boy in the in the MMF
threesome for you it's like no you're
not gonna have him he's mine I'm in like
the playful nature of that I've had an
MMF with a married couple oh really yeah
it's uh it wasn't a relationship it was
just well it was a relationship in the
nature there was like a sexual
relationship but like did you guys live
together no no we just hooked up just
I'm talking about MMF porn category just
like we would we would hook up like yeah
it was like so he was like
I'll say this in a way that I want
people to know he like is pretty
straight but she was like oh would you
be would you two or would you two be
okay kissing and it was like okay with
kissing and stuff and I think it was him
like also figuring out what he wanted in
that situation so I think
the more that we kind of like test the
waters with this and the more that we
allow people to be like oh okay let me
watch this and not just watch it as porn
just watch it to be like well okay what
do I not like about this what do I like
about this maybe I'm actually more
attracted to like uh a FFM situation
maybe I want to see him with another
girl so I know that's what he could be
doing to me instead of my fear of that
that stuff that he's doing that guy
won't even be you can't even apply those
course credits to this you're that's not
gonna work with me you I need to you
need to be taking a class that you can
actually use you know what I mean like
telling people to get a degree and
something that's useful it's like that's
what I think you're not evil you're not
like I think internalized homophobia I
do a lot of externally gay [__] but I
still have internalized homophobia
because I grew up in America I grew up
in Mississippi that [__] can get like
chipped away at but the core of it will
always be there and I'm able to go okay
I can rationalize but some stuff still
is like oh no like it's almost like the
desire sometimes that you have when
you're around cool straight dudes to
like Bush it up and you're like but girl
you're gonna get on stage and talk about
your wedding so why are you being Broly
around the dudes just because it makes
you feel a little better okay
yeah interesting I wonder if it helped
me to see family members growing up like
I would see my uncles and my male
cousins who were in who were married
with children but on the weekend when
the whole family would go out to like
the province say for instance I would
see my uncles and my older male cousins
hook up with dudes and it was sort of
like an agreement between them that like
no one would talk about it but I just
saw it a lot and kind of no one made a
fuss about it and then they just carried
on in their marriages like nothing and I
feel like as though their wives knew so
like maybe that shaped my idea or why
it's not so like uh shocking to me like
it's very normal for me to see a man go
either direction and it's not a turn off
for me that may totally make sense
that's but that's like such a cool story
that's like casual you but in my head I
was like
well to be fair the men in my family
were horrible husbands horrible dads
which is why they always cheated but
then the cheating was so open and I even
the young kids their kids saw it you
know what I mean so but I would see them
cheat on their wives with men and I was
just like oh I guess this is just what
we do as a family you know so
um as [__] up as it was dude Catholics
are weird man Catholics are weird like
my my same cousin Mary he has six six
Sons surprisingly but he was like the
biggest meth dealer on my Island but he
would never miss Mass on Sunday and he
would take the kalawat the bread and
everyone would just be like all is good
in the world so it was really confusing
for me to be like what is happening here
does Catholicism like turn sex or gay
sex all sex like into this naughty evil
thing so then it makes sense if you want
it more yeah like when you're kidding
kids who grew up in households where you
can't have candy and then you grow up
and do all you want is go to one
person's house I'm like you want some
candy you're like yeah
do you understand how much [__] candy
I'm about to do you don't do okay
I'm doing this [__] can
please make that a bit oh my God I don't
do candy
very weird credit card I'm about to do
this
way thank you so much for doing you ever
out of me this was so much fun this is
more like the coolest you're very
coolest Superstar are you on tour right
now where can people find all right so
you can find me on social media at
jayjerden
j-a-y-j-u-r-d-e-n it's spelled the same
across all platforms I am on like a tiny
kinda sort of tour I'm a writer for the
problem with Jon Stewart and so I we
have a little bit of a break right now
so I was just uh I was just in Royal Oak
but I'm gonna be in Chicago I'm gonna be
in Boston I'm gonna be in Arlington I'm
going to be in Bloomington I'll put all
that stuff on all my social media
Bloomington is yeah most common yeah
where are you playing in Chicago I'm
gonna be a Zanies
yeah Portillo's sandwich okay oh yeah
naughties go CJ and wait what's your
website uh jarden.com so everything is
just my name if you type my name in
Google I should be the one that comes up
and honestly you guys have to see his
stand up it's so smart and funny and
like real like your standup is exactly
the style that I really respond to
because it's
it's not just jokes for jokes it's like
you are expressing who you are and how
you feel and it's funny it means a lot I
love your stuff too so when you saying
that means a lot it really does everyone
thank you for being here and please come
back anytime thank you
thank you
[Music]